the fifth generation of wireless
technology has made it to cities in the
United States across the country
t-mobile Sprint and others are laying
the foundation for a faster better
internet but in the race to develop 5g
us firms are already at a disadvantage
they have limited access to some other
radio frequencies that enable 5g and
operators worried that there's not
enough space to meet anticipated demand
in Chicago
Verizon download speeds reached a
maximum above 1 gigabyte per second
while maximum ZAR interesting median
speeds say more about coverage look in
South Korea and you'll see higher median
speeds that means their networks may be
faster in more scenarios to understand
why the US has a disadvantage you've got
to understand how wireless technology
like 5g works most wireless systems rely
on radio waves that can carry signals
back and forth between your device and a
service provider to run these systems
firms like sprint or Vodafone have to
buy space in the radio frequency
spectrum the left side of the spectrum
chart represents low frequencies radio
waves in this portion of spectrum are
long and can travel farther distances
think of it like playing heavy bass in a
building the low frequencies can be
heard from a distance even if they
travel through solid objects like walls
frequencies toward the middle left of
this chart are in the mid band these
frequencies between 1 and 6 gigahertz
are quite useful they're low enough to
send signals along distance but they
have an advantage they can carry more
data than low bands some versions of 4G
and Wi-Fi live in this sweet spot band
the main issue here is that space is
limited move to the right and the
frequencies get higher still as
frequencies get higher their wavelengths
shrink shorter wavelengths let engineers
cram more data into their radio signal
firms in the United States are mostly
building 5g networks in this higher
frequency portion of spectrum the
ultra-fast download speeds and low
latency will enable developments in
self-driving cars and virtual reality
but the short wavelengths here present
technical issues for starters the waves
don't travel very far this means that
your signal might not work indoors or if
anything blocks in your line of sight to
the tower like a tree the inability to
travel great distances also means that
cities will need to install several
nodes to ensure a blanket of coverage
the build out of that infrastructure
will not be cheap so why are US firms at
a disadvantage it has to do with
governance the international
telecommunication union divides the
world into three regions within the
regions countries negotiate to reserve
frequencies operators then bid for a
portion think of it like an auction for
invisible real estate in the United
States two groups control that bidding
process the FCC holds auctions for
private groups like Sprint and t-mobile
and the NTIA does the same for federal
agencies like the Defense Department the
department defense has traditionally
been one of the biggest spectrum users
in the US and so they are the incumbent
in MIDI band and any band where you
could move them out has been done long
ago as a result US firms have left space
to build 5g networks that balance higher
data speeds with reasonable coverage
countries and other regions have more
access to that spectrum sweet spot so
China Japan and South Korea are building
out mid band and high band all at once
for its part the FCC wants to help
domestic firms roll out 5g fast my plan
includes three key components freeing up
spectrum promoting wireless
infrastructure and modernizing
regulations the FCC is moving forward
aggressively on all fronts the 3-5 g
related auctions in 2019 for those
faster high bands which means that early
rollouts in the united states will
mostly be that fast download limited
coverage flavor of 5g firms and other
countries don't have that limitation
because they have more access to the mid
band their 5g networks will offer wide
coverage alongside blazing fast speeds
many analysts anticipate that companies
in China will lead the charge toward a
mid
van type 5g and leading the global
market early is important according to
the defense innovation board previous
market leaders in wireless tech set
standards that the rest of the world had
to follow that's good for business
analysts say that US firms have some
flexibility to repurpose their existing
mid band spectrum ATT for example will
introduce their mid band sub six network
in 2020 as the decade advances firms in
the United States are expected to lobby
for more access across the spectrum but
those negotiations will take time
one FCC Commissioner said that in the
past these agreements have taken five to
ten years which means that for the
near-term 5g in the US will be fast but
not very accessible
[Music]
you